[Music]
yep it's likely that by now you've heard
about movie mass the subscription
service that allows you to see one movie
per day in theaters for 995 a month
except you can't see a movie more than
once you have to be a hundred yards from
the theatre to book the ticket and
during certain men to pay a little extra
but despite all that movie pass is still
a pretty good deal in fact the deal
might be too good for movie past just so
you've probably heard about movie past
you've probably also heard the company
is losing money faster than a Tarantino
henchman loses blood the problem is
simple movie pass charges 995 a month
and the average movie ticket in America
costs nine dollars and 16 cents when you
see a movie with movie pass they pay the
full price of the ticket as if they were
buying a normal ticket for a friend that
means if you see just two movies a month
movie passes losing double what it gains
from you more if you're buying in a city
where ticket prices are more expensive
multiply that by 3 million friends and
you can see why movie Pass is in a lot
of trouble financially according to the
best estimates the average movie path
subscriber sees about 1.5 movies a month
and even though that's not three movies
or even two the numbers are still
lopsided and that point 5 of a movie is
bleeding them dry in 2017 the company
that owns movie Pass Helios and Matheson
lost a hundred and fifty million dollars
and in May the company revealed in an
SEC filing that it's losing 21 point
seven million dollars per month on
average at that time and at that rate
they only had enough cash available to
stay solvent for two more months it's
two months later now and well the
website still works so that's a good
sign if you're consistently losing money
as a business there's only one way to
stay afloat by finding investors to give
you money in the hope that someday
you'll be profitable in the future
investors like those investing in
Spotify or uber or Dropbox or blue apron
all companies that have yet to become
profitable in fact of the 108 companies
that went public in 2017 over
three-quarters weren't profitable yeah
now not all unprofitable companies are
created equal
Amazon was unprofitable for years but it
had the revenues it was just putting
them back into investments in the case
of movie pass the
the new just isn't enough to pay for the
costs that movie path says it
understands this it says it always knew
it was going to lose money on its path
to acquiring more subscribers and
greater market share and to be fair the
growth of the company has been
impressive
last August movie pass only had 20,000
subscribers when they lowered their
price to $10 a month almost a year later
and they're approaching 3 million with
projections of up to 5 million by the
end of the year the theory behind the
price drop and the reason they haven't
yet raised it substantially to stem
their losses is that it's supposed to
attract the 51% of moviegoers who only
see about 3 to 6 movies a year people
who might pass on $20 or even $15 but
can't resist 10 these people the theory
goes we'll bring the average movie per
subscriber down but movie path needs to
look for cash in other places too the
original idea was that it could use the
app to track the movie going habits of
its users and sell that data to studios
for targeted advertising and to
restaurants nearby the theater who could
advertise to customers when they're in
the area movie pass thinks that
eventually if it can grow enough it can
negotiate a percentage of the new
business it's bringing to theaters and
the surrounding stores it thinks that it
could potentially even get a slice of a
theaters only real money maker
concessions let's see what the CEO of
America's largest theater chain has to
say about that AMC is absolutely no
intention I repeat no intention of
sharing any I repeat any of our
admissions revenue or our concessions
revenue [ __ ] okay I added that last
part I was getting into it there are a
lot of forces at work in the movie feed
or ecosystem and movie paths is laying
them all bare people are seeing fewer
movies overall so theater chains have
been raising ticket prices and higher
ticket prices means people see fewer
movies still and don't take chances on
what they do see theaters have it hard
as it is most ticket revenues get kicked
back to the studios who leverage their
power to get even more percentage and
now here comes a subscription service
devaluing the price of a ticket in the
minds of consumers asking for a cut of
concessions
and yet movie pass is bringing them
business its users are taking chances
again seeing movies on a whim again it's
bringing more people to the movies more
often it's just not bringing enough
people not yet the studio's don't want
to pay for the data the theaters don't
want to cut them in and movie pass
subscribers are just seeing too many
movies there's a size at which this
would all change 20 million subscribers
maybe or 50 million a hundred I don't
know but it's a race now can movie pass
get to that critical size before it runs
completely out of money I guess we'll
see until then it is genuinely one of
the best deals in town something I
thought I'd never see a bunch of rich
investors taking millions of people out
to the movies everybody thank you so
much for watching this episode was
brought to you by skill share an online
learning community for creators with
more than 18,000 classes and everything
from graphic design to film editing to
finance and IT security you know when I
learned Photoshop I learned it through
this mishmash of disconnected YouTube
videos and I think the process would
have gone a lot faster if there was a
class dedicated to teaching me
everything about that program in a
systematic way learning new skills is
really valuable to me because whenever I
learn a new skill it's like a bunch of
new ideas are suddenly unlocked in my
head I think what can I do with this and
that always always helps me with
writer's block
a premium membership begins around $10 a
month for unlimited access to all
courses but the first 500 people to sign
up using the link in the description
below will get their first two months
for free in those two months you could
easily learn the skills you need to
start a new hobby or business more
importantly the skills you learn will
help give you the ideas for what that
business or our project could be
definitely try it out thanks guys I'll
see you next time